The One Piece manga just CONFIRMED the shocking
end of the conflict on Pirate Island, where
Monkey D. Garp was defeated and most likely
captured by the Blackbeard Pirates.
Which is absolutely game changing for the
story because this will surely lead to some
world altering events that could involve the
Marines, Cross Guild, the Straw hats, and
even the secret ruler of the world, Imu.
And that’s not the only thing that happened
in this chapter because Koby also revealed
what could be the future justice system of
the marines, plus he demonstrated his incredible
new strength for the very first time.
To top it off, we finally seem to be headed
back to Egghead Island in the very near future
where we will finally see the events that
will shock the world.
But whatever twists are to come during Egghead,
it is going to be hard to live up to the insanity
of the Hero of the Marines being defeated.
Because back in chapter 1071 when Garp first
announced he was going to save Koby, I don’t
think ANYONE seriously thought that he would
lose and be captured like this.
Because in this chapter Garp nearly takes
out the island man Pizzaro all by himself
and shows off his impressive speed that even
surprises the former admiral Kuzan, but he
eventually gets surrounded by the Blackbeard
pirates.
Koby and the others have made it safely to
the escaping ship, which we’ll discuss more
in just a moment, and even though Koby wants
to return to help Garp, he is already being
frozen by Kuzan, just like what happened to
Saul back in chapter 397.
Now
before we go any further into what this means
for Garp’s future let’s talk about what
this means for Kuzan.
And even though at this point you might say
it is major copium, I’m still not convinced
Kuzan is evil because maybe the ice man knew
that Garp was going to die from his stab wound
in the last chapter, so freezing him was a
way to keep him alive while his body heals,
kinda like going into cryofreeze.
Plus I’m sure the rest of the Blackbeard
pirates would have kept stabbing and shooting
Garp until they knew he was dead, but if he
is frozen then it makes sense that they stopped.
And It is also a convenient way to keep
Garp trapped, although we’ve seen characters
break out of ice before.
Before we get back to Garp’s future, there
is one other mind-blowing point I want to
make about what all this means for Kuzan.
Because if you look at the title of this chapter,
it is called “Last Lesson”.
So I’m wondering if this scene where Garp
sacrifices himself to save Koby is actually
the so-called last lesson that Garp is trying
to teach Kuzan.
Because if Garp is willing to give up his
life to protect the person that he most believes
in, then maybe Kuzan is being set up to do
the very same thing in the future.
And if we are thinking along these lines,
then the person that makes the most sense
for him to sacrifice himself for would definitely
be Nico Robin.
Because as we pointed out in the last chapter,
Kuzan let her live after the destruction of
Ohara, and ever since he has been waiting
to see what kind of person she will become.
So could we see him give up his life to save
Robin during the fight between Blackbeard’s
crew and the Straw Hats?
But whatever Kuzan’s future role is, I think
it is fair to say that we all thought Garp’s
role would be a whole lot different than we
see at the end of this chapter.
I mean he is the Hero of the Marines and many
consider him the strongest marine.
Plus he is Luffy’s grandpa which means he
should have some major role in the story.
Which could still turn out to be the case
just not in the way we were expecting.
And in the last chapter review, we speculated
on exactly what could happen in the future
if Garp was indeed captured.
To sum it up, there are essentially three
options for what the Blackbeard pirates could
do with Garp.
First, they could straight up kill him, but
since Kuzan took the trouble to freeze him,
that doesn’t seem likely at this point.
The second option was for the Blackbeard pirates
to hand Garp over to Cross Guild to set up
a sort of Reverse Marineford, where the pirates
are executing a marine.
And the third option was for Blackbeard to
try to ransom Garp to the World Government
in exchange for being recognized as an official
kingdom.
And at this point, I don’t think any of
those options have changed, but since it is
now confirmed that Garp is defeated, let’s
dive a bit deeper into how each of these options
could play out and why they make sense for
the story.
As I already said, the option I still think
is most unlikely is Garp straight up dying
right now.
I mean the only purpose that would serve is
to inspire Luffy to get revenge and for Koby
to inherit Garp’s will of being a great,
honest marine.
Which just doesn't seem epic enough for a
character like Garp at this point
But that is nowhere near as exciting as if
Garp gets turned over to Cross Guild for an
execution.
And with a 3 Billion berry bounty, I kinda
wonder how the leaders of Cross Guild would
even pay that amount, but let’s assume they
do get their hands on Garp, then we could
be in for a global broadcast execution on
the scale of Marineford.
And I’m sure Garp’s marine friends would
come to save him unless they were ordered
not to.
Which might cause even more marines to resign
if that were to happen.
I’d also expect Luffy to come save his Grandpa.
Shanks could show up as well, which could
actually have disastrous consequences, which
we’ll discuss more in just a moment.
Honestly though, I don’t think Oda would
have another execution style epic war just
for the sake of it, so let’s analyze some
of the reasons Marineford was so impactful
on the story.
First, before the war even started the darkness
fruit user snuck into Impel Down and recruited
some powerful prisoners onto his crew.
So if we are having another kind of war like
Marineford, I wonder if Blackbeard would try
to do something similar and steal another
prisoner out of Impel Down.
And if you are wondering who that might be,
well look no further than this pink guy.
No, wait, not that one.
This one.
That’s right, you may have forgotten that
Doflamingo is still in jail, but he is AND
more importantly he knows some of the world
government's deepest secrets knows, in particular
the national treasure of Mary Geoise, which
still hasn't been confirmed exactly what this
is.
And that is exactly the type of information
that I am sure Blackbeard would love to get
his hands on.
Which brings us to the next important aspect
of Marineford, which was that the person being
executed had someone very special to them
try to rescue them.
And that special person - which was Whitebeard
- ended up dying.
But what’s important about the former Yonko’s
death was that it was all part of Blackbeard’s
plot to steal a second devil fruit.
So if we have a second Marineford style war,
even if it was a smaller scale, this could
be another opportunity for Blackbeard to swoop
in and steal another super powerful devil
fruit.
Maybe Luffy's, Sengoku's Buddha Fruit, or
one of the admirals' powers might make sense.
Or if it wasn’t a devil fruit that Blackbeard
is after, maybe he could be coming to steal
Poneglyph copies during the chaos of the fighting.
And if we focus on Whitebeard dying, the final
thing I could see possibly happening in this
scenario is Blackbeard taking advantage of
the fighting to finally have his long-awaited
showdown with Shanks.
Because at Marineford, Shanks offered to fight
Blackbeard, but the darkness fruit user said
that this wasn’t the time for them to fight.
So what better opportunity to finally have
this epic clash than at a Reverse Marineford?
And if they fight, I would certainly be sweating
that Shanks could die in this scenario.
Because I mean we all know Blackbeard is one
of Luffy’s end game villains, so he probably
won’t be defeated by anyone other than Luffy.
But that’s not even the most insane character
that Blackbeard might defeat out of this whole
situation, so make sure to subscribe to the
channel for more One Piece content like this.
And I say that because if Blackbeard doesn’t
hand Garp over to Cross Guild then the other
likely option is that he tries to ransom the
Hero of the Marines in exchange for Pirate
Island being officially recognized as part
of the world government.
Of course that would make Blackbeard king,
which if I'm being honest it is entirely possible
the world government would simply refuse and
not give Blackbeard what he wants.
But let’s assume for a minute that they
do agree and Blackbeard becomes an official
king of the world government.
And I’m warning you right now, strap on
your seatbelts because if this happens could
change everything that we know about the final
war at the end of the story.
To set this up, let’s head back to chapter
907, where we are first introduced to the
Empty Throne in Mary Geoise.
Here we can see that this annoying guy right
here is making his oath as the new king of
the Goa Kingdom.
To do this he is supposed to place a blade
before the empty throne and swear to not try
to seek control over other kingdoms.
Now, no one really cares about Stelly, but
this is important to think about if we are
considering Blackbeard could become an official
king of the world government.
Because it is reasonable to assume that Blackbeard
would also be required to come in and make
this oath before the empty throne.
Of course, Blackbeard would probably never
make that promise, but the key point is that
Blackbeard would supposedly have access to
Mary Geoise.
And man my mind just goes crazy when thinking
about Blackbeard strolling around the Holy
Land.
Because who is to say that Blackbeard doesn’t
already know about some of the secrets hidden
up here on top of the Red Line.
Could he know about Imu?
Or is there some other secret like a devil
fruit tree that he might be interested in?
There are so many possibilities in this scenario!
But if all of this does happen and Blackbeard
finds himself in the castle, then I could
see something happening that could completely
change the entire story.
Because in chapter 1085 we were first shown
the Gorosei and Imu’s powers.
And while these powers were kept in silhouette,
many people have also speculated that Imu
really does have some sort of powers relating
to darkness, shadow, or nightmares.
So I am super curious how these powers would
fare against Blackbeard’s darkness fruit
powers.
Could Blackbeard’s darkness negate Imu’s
abilities?
And if they fight then the outcome could shake
the entire world.
I mean can you imagine if Blackbeard somehow
took out Imu and the Gorosei?
Which might sound crazy, but just think about
it for a moment.
One thing that has always been strange to
me about end game One Piece is that there
are basically two final boss type characters.
Blackbeard and Imu.
And if we assume that Luffy is supposed to
fight Blackbeard for the One Piece, then does
he go and fight Imu after that?
Or does Imu come to Laugh Tale?
It honestly seems a bit weird since finding
the one piece has always seemed like the climax
of the story.
So wouldn’t it make sense if these two final
bosses fought each other and only one emerged
as the final super villain?
Wow, we are way deep into theory territory
here.
And you might think I am crazy for speculating
all of this based on the simple fact of Garp
being captured.
But we've already seen how much a single event
can change the world.
Just look back at Ace being captured and all
of the mind-blogging madness that resulted
in.
But there are a few other super interesting
points from the chapter that hint at endgame
outcomes for One Piece.
The first is that we see Koby finally unleash
an impressive attack, which is called Honesty
Impact.
With his a haki covered fist that very much
resembles Garp’s devastatingly powerful
Galaxy Impact that we just saw in chapter
1080, he completely destroys the giant hand
that is about to crush the escaping marine
vessel.
Koby has learned a thing or two from Garp,
but what I am most interested in is the “Honesty”
part of the attack name because I think this
could be important foreshadowing for the type
of Justice that Koby will embrace when he
eventually becomes an admiral in the marines.
I mean it goes along with his character, and
it is a stark contrast to the corruption that
exists in the current world government and
marines.
The world government is actually incredibly
dishonest in many situations, especially when
they tried to cover up the horrible events
in Alabasta and Dressrosa.
So I’m definitely looking forward to some
change in philosophy that Koby will likely
bring in the future.
Plus we finally got to see more of why exactly
Garp believes so much in Koby, because we
get to see many of their interactions during
Koby’s time training and see just how hard
he hard to work to become as strong as he
has.
But that’s the only impressive thing he
does because we also get to see exactly how
Koby ended up captured by Blackbeard.
In chapter 1059 we saw the start of this conflict
on Amazon Lily, where Blackbeard attacked
with the hope of taking the pirate Empress
Boa Hancock’s devil fruit.
And while the Yonko was stopped by a combination
of Koby, the Seraphim, and Silver’s Rayleigh,
it turns out that Blackbeard was going to
take hundreds of marines with his as prisoner.
That is until Koby traded himself for all
of those marines, which is how he ended up
captured.
And if that’s not what you call being a
“hero” than I don’t know what is, so
it makes even more sense now why Garp has
so much faith in Koby.
Shifting back to the end of the chapter, we
got a narrator box which explained that tomorrow’s
newspaper has information that Koby was safe,
Garp disappeared on Pirate Island, and apparently
that Luffy is going to claim Egghead Island
as his own territory.
Now we have to keep in mind that this is the
newspaper which usually exaggerates things,
but regardless it seems we finally shift back
to Egghead Island.
We even get to see that the ships carrying
Saint Saturn and Admiral Kizaru are finally
pulling up to the island.
So After nine whole chapters away, we are
finally going to return for the conclusion
of this arc that we were literally told will
shock the world.
And wow I am so excited to see the straw hats
again, in particular their inevitable encounter
with Saint Saturn.
After seeing a bit of what his powers can
do in chapter 1085 I simply cannot wait to
see him and Admiral Kizaru in action against
Luffy.
However, we have to remember that they are
not the only ones here.
Because we also know that someone from Blackbeard’s
crew is here as well, which brings us back
to the question of what they could also be
doing here.
And one idea that I saw on Twitter from 3SkullJoe
was that Blackbeard could be bringing Big
Mom’s daughter, Pudding, to try and use
her devil fruit powers to get some top secret
information out of Vegapunk.
In case you forgot, Pudding has the memory
devil fruit, which lets her see and manipulate
a person’s memories.
So if Pudding is forced to use her powers
on the genius scientist, I wonder what information
he could be after.
Plans for some incredibly powerful technology?
Secrets about the Void Century or how to read
the poneglyphs?
And even if this isn’t the case, Blackbeard
might be able to use Pudding on the newly
captured Garp to retrieve some memories from
the Hero of the Marines.
And what memories might Blackbeard be after
in this case?
Well, how about information about the person
who inspired Blackbeard, Rocks D. Xebec?
After all, Garp was the one who defeated Rocks
with the help of Roger, so he is sure to know
information about the infamous pirate from
forty years ago.
And hold on, if this were to happen then does
that mean we could actually get a real flashback
to the events of God Valley?
If I’m being honest, I have been dying to
see the legendary clash between Roger, Garp,
and Rocks, which I bet would undoubtedly be
one of the most hyped up moments in the entire
story.
And if all of this has got you wanting a pure
injection of the most badass moments in the
entire story, then you can check out my ranking
of the most exciting moments in one piece
right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.